Thick Smoke belongs Over The Hills near
chanakale Central District as one Fire
gets put out another appears to ignite
during the Region's Wildfire season
according to Turkish authorities there
hasn't been any deaths
but 63 year old Mahmoud from ulupunar
Village counts the 35 sheep he lost in
The Inferno as casualties
he believes his village was ignored
because the fires were small at first
the planes and helicopters went to
another Village also caught in The Blaze
I'm angry I'm angry because I lost my
animals it's not because they were my
belongings but they were pregnant
according to the Agriculture and
Forester Ministry the fires have burnt
1500 hectares of land and have been
circled to prevent further spread this
is the last one they are attempting to
control
emergency responders have managed to
make progress in containing a patchwork
of fires in some areas but this one here
across solapunar Village hasn't stopped
since Tuesday and the persistent winds
are making it worse
hundreds of individuals have been
treated for smoke inhalation as a result
of the fire forcing them to flee their
homes according to officials more than 1
200 people from nine Villages have been
evacuated from the fire path and 83
people have been hospitalized thus far
the annual wildfires in Mediterranean
Basin have increased due to climate
change but authorities here also blame
the human factor see Namco solo Al
Jazeera chanakale Northwestern trickier
foreign